The Joe Rogan Experience I've heard you
say that you believe that what
psychedelics do is make the mind more
fertile for these experiences that's a
good way to yes that's exactly what I
think I think you're at that level where
the ego's control has dissolved to some
degree
and says like fertile ground and so if
you've whatever
pre-20 or if you're ready for mystical
experience you're more likely to have it
in that experience in that state of mind
so the mind is actually restricting us
in many ways through the ego from having
these experiences yeah I think so and
what psychedelics do is release those
boundaries yes I think that
due to the um
evolution of man
homo sapiens and are taking taking the
upright position
this is a theory I was introduced to
in 1966 and actually
I think a lot of the details are
probably wrong but in concept I think is
true
which is
um the ape standing upright
one thing people haven't taken into
account is obviously there are hundreds
of assets are standing upright free or
harmlessly run faster you see further
all of them
but
in that right position gravity is
against the blood in the brain
it's in the brain they're too fluid
volumes of blood and cerebral spinal
fluid
which is water basically which is made
in the brain itself
so it has kind of squatters right in the
brain
so
um when you're in that reposition
gravity is pulling the blood down
so I think probably with that position
we lost
a small proportion about blood supply I
mean some animals you tie them up right
a dog food if it's tied up so you can't
get down it will start hardly can go mad
because
it hasn't got the valves to keep the
blood up and we've obviously got a
certain amount but maybe we lost some
blood at that upright position
and as a compensation for that loss
I think we
developed an internal mechanism more
than any other animal has done it which
is to direct the blood where it most
needs to go obviously all animals do
that they have the part to
send the blood was most important to
survival or whatever
and I think that through the use of the
conditioned sound the word
we learned to control that
process more than any other animal and
over the Millennia we kind of build up
our power to do that so
I think that's the secret of why humans
you know what is it a talking talking
app
got control of the whole game because of
our creation of language which enables
us to do these incredible things we do
yes but it also has a disadvantage
that are basic state is slightly low in
blood
in the dominant organ
so we have to keep this
this mechanism of tight control and
where the blood is distributed and that
is evolved with the ego
which is essential I mean we wouldn't
survive without the ego to kind of
um
direct the blood where it's most needed
people who lose their ego
and in the 60s when people took large
doses of
LST as it was then every day sometimes
they lost their ego they slipped out
and there was one occasion of someone
who knew who was in Ibiza
and he'd flipped out and he put the key
in his the lock to open the door
someone would say goodnight to him he
put the key in the lock and left him and
then in the morning he was still there
with the key in the door because the
head hadn't told him turn the key down
wow we need the words to keep us you
know yes
under control
yeah
it the words have made us what we are
this incredible animal who can
um you know have a nuclear war if we
want or know the atoms in the body all
those brilliant things we do which is
amazing
but we're also obviously a very deeply
faulted animal at some point
well um
you know neurotic psychotic psychotic
you know
um
all of those things because of this
um shortage of blood and then the
dependent on the meaning of the word so
if we have a terrible conditioning
a lot of people do yes
um
the the the separation from reality
is in a sense in the meaning of the word
um
so
the danger of our society now in a sense
is we're getting further and further
away from
nature
in a sense
and that in a way is why psychedelics
can be a very
useful medicine
because they increase
the connectivity with the senses with
the with the internal bodily senses and
also the outside perceptual senses
um
so
I actually think that
we're entering a kind of new possible
age and that's why fun I call it the
Psychedelic age
because for the first time we've got or
getting
the knowledge by which we can actually
understand the brain better and
understand
how we can alter
the volume of blood in the brain which
is giving the brain energy the whole
thing is about energy
the more energy we have the more parts
of the brain can function simultaneously
and um
that obviously
can be very
um
creative stimulating
empathic by just having more of the
brain functioning
um
and so I think that
the knowledge of
psychedelics and when I say psychedelics
I don't actually mean necessarily
psychedelics because as we all know one
can get these experiences endogenously
through exercise or
um holotropic breathing hydrotropic
bleeding exactly or breathing exercise I
mean all the spiritual training
all knew that that's what they were
doing in the spiritual disciplines is
teaching people how to control
now internal
eager and also their sense of
consciousness
and I think at the center of the
spiritual experience is the getting
higher and loosening
the grip of the eager so you're more in
touch with nature do you think that in
the absence of these psychedelic
experiences one of the problems with
words is that we develop narratives and
then we use our ego to reinforce these
narratives and we sort of deny objective
reality yes I think more and more the
word can become
the reality I mean in the creation of
Words which we all have and have to have
a thankful to have but nevertheless it
does create
a new uh uh a slightly different world
it's rather like um the Shadows on
Plato's wall and get one's internal
edition of the world
rather than the real experience of the
world
and so
um
I think it's I think it's good to be in
contact with nature and I think
it's it's a dangerous path that we're
taking now where it becomes more and
more
um life is the screen
um but still that's where we're going
and um and it has great advantages as
well as dangerous kind of thing
but
but I do think that the knowledge of
getting
High has always been Central
to the human
evolution
and at the earliest
um
demonstrations of what we've got of the
earliest demonstrations of human culture
say the caves in Chauvet do you know
that yeah yeah which I I think they've
never been battered I mean that that
artwork the brush Strokes of those
animals they're alive you can see the
movement no one ever did it better and
it's like 30 something thousand years
old exactly 35 40 something around there
wow so they
I can tell because I
um some respects an artist I know those
Strokes what's this pull up some of
those images jamming because some of
those images yeah here we go yeah
amazing stuff they're just incredible
yeah the movement of that yeah yeah it
did create a feeling of movement like
the animals were running yeah and the
the lines I mean
anyone who paints I mean um Picasso I
think said without them he would have
never done what he did or I can't
remember quite but
a modern art isn't better it gets as
good but not really it's crazy because
they're depicting rhinos too yeah really
wild that there was rhinos in France
yeah beautiful ones of horses and
Buffalos and yeah um
um and so and that's in the bowels of
the earth they're doing a very spiritual
fly go into the bowels of the earth if
it's the kind of magical spiritual
experience they're having yeah and so I
I think without doubt
um
they were high how they got there was it
through singing drumming or um singing
or was it through taking compounds funny
enough I've recently been introduced met
Charming man whose archaeologist in
charge of survey and I said I'd love to
be able to analyze and see if we can
find out
if there's any remnants right there's
some psychological substance or
something and he said I was very welcome
to go there so I'm very excited about
the possibility